la nueva ley de francia contra el
separatismo endurece las reglas sobre la
educación en el hogar tras rectificar su
prohibición total los padres que quieran
educar a sus hijos en casa deberán
obtener permiso de las autoridades
educativas locales se establecerán
excepciones especiales para niños con
discapacidades y problemas de salud la
ley también castigará la difusión del
odio en línea sancionando a quienes
ponen en peligro la vida de las personas
al publicar información sobre su vida
privada los infractores de la ley
podrían ser sancionados con hasta tres
años de prisión y una multa de unos
54.000 dólares se espera que los
trabajadores de empresas privadas
encargadas de realizar un servicio
estatal como los trabajadores de los
aeropuertos por ejemplo respeten el
principio de neutralidad no habrá
excepciones para nadie por motivos
religiosos precisamente los grupos
religiosos también deberán declarar las
donaciones por valor superior a los 12
mil dólares que provengan del exterior
el gobierno espera que la medida
debilite la influencia extranjera en los
lugares de culto las ong también van a
ser controladas con funcionarios que
obtendrían más poderes para actuar
contra grupos que se crea que están
difundiendo el extremismo las
organizaciones que soliciten
y estatales deberán firmar un contrato
adhiriéndose a los valores republicanos
quienes incumplan el contrato deberán
devolver el dinero estatal entregado en
cuanto a los derechos de las mujeres
ahora los médicos tendrán prohibido
entregar los llamados certificados de
virginidad la ley también refuerza los
poderes del estado para reprimir los
matrimonios forzados si la poligamia